i am dr. Madero Suspiria go and the
director of an American else can I say
decision for the Americans and I am also
the chair of the Global Agenda Council
on chronic diseases and well-being and I
would like to respond to the question
regarding its use participation
important economic edible for the
economic development of Latin American
how should game people get involved I
think that the region is going now so a
window of opportunity that we call the
demographic bonus which is that they
have more young people and dependent
people which are children and older
population of 65 across so this is a
demographic bonus will last for only 10
years more and we need to invest in the
u.s. also because we are facing and
precedents iteration in the region many
countries are dropping very fast very
quickly their infant
great but the use mortality rate is
increasing and that's because of the
frustration the lack of future the lack
of trust and confidence in the future of
the world of the youth are because of
their high unemployment rates and they
get into risky behaviors including pile
and suicide drug abuse that is creating
a high-risk tall for the young people
individual